[Arabic recitation]
[Silence]
Continuing with the descriptions of the
hellfire
as related to us by Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala in the middle verses of surah mud
the second chapter of the Quran to be
revealed to our prophet Sam
when we say and when we read and hear
from our scholars that this is the
second chapter revealed or for instance
this is the first chapter of the Quran
to be revealed.
Does it necessarily mean
that every verse was revealed all at
once that is part of that chapter? The
answer is no. The chapters of the Quran
were not all revealed
together as a chapter.
some of them were, some of the longer
ones were, but that's very rare. And
many of the shorter chapters were
revealed all together all at once as a
unit. However, a huge portion of the
chapters of the Quran were revealed in
pieces in parts over a 23year span.
As many of us know
is no different. The opening verses were
the were the second thing to be revealed
to him of the Quran. However, the
remaining verses of surah mud,
it is very clear from the tone, from the
topics discussed, from the things that
are mentioned and the people that are
mentioned that these verses were
revealed perhaps even years after the
opening verses were revealed. So this is
something good to keep in mind
because the chapters when they are
mentioned to be revealed in a certain
order it doesn't necessarily mean that
they were all that the chapter was
revealed as a whole. Some of them were
but not all of them. Right? And so when
you're reading this
for instance a person says I would like
to read the most vivid
seal the most vivid book on the prophet
Muhammad's saiam
what book is that what book do we start
with and learning about his s
the Quran number one it seems a
trick question right but Yeah, a lot of
times this is overlooked.
he mentioned
the sealed nectar. This book is
incredibly important. It's very
important for us specifically for us.
Why for us? Because
he's not mentioning something new.
There's no new cutting edge discoveries
being made on the prophet's seal. As a
matter of fact, the further away in time
we become from his time, the more we
have to go through in order to reach
the more literature and research we have
to go through in order to reach what
and discern his silo. But why do
scholars then keep writing books on the
same topics? Because the sealer didn't
change but the readers do change. the
reader has changed. our languages
change, our cultures change, our
environments change. And so as a result
of this, it becomes much more difficult
for us to understand what the earlier
scholars are writing about. So the
scholars of Islam and every time
constantly are writing the same thing
over but in a more relatable language
and trying to close that chasm that
is between us and that time period which
was 1,500 years ago. I might I mean we
might as well have been from a different
planet. I mean everything has changed
since then especially in the last
hundred years. Our entire world has
changed. So for instance an example of
this this is a little bit off topic but
an example of this for those of us here
who speak Arabic and those of us who
even don't speak Arabic you probably
know this word when I say the word
hammen. Ham
what what does that mean?
we had a little kid say yes a young
upand cominging he says a bathroom
right what what pops into your mind when
I say the word him or bathroom in in
in English which bathroom by the way
that particular word is an exact
translation
almost exact translation of the word h
what pops into your mind the bathroom
that you've all, you know, unless you're
200 years old or you grew up
overseas,
the bathroom that's in your house, in my
house, in the masjid, everywhere you go
in, there's a shower, there's a a
toilet, there's a sink. Pretty standard
stuff. That's not what the word ham
means in the Sunnah. That's not what the
word ham means in the narrations of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam. The
prophet sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam
prohibited the attendance of al ham.
It's per it's prohibited to attend the
ham in in some narrations. What does
that mean? What what is that? Even the
word bathroom in English doesn't mean
what it used to mean. the word bathroom.
It's a place where it was a public space
where people would all get naked
together and they would collectively
heat water there and people would go to
bathe. There's no place to relieve
yourself in a right and so just that one
word changes
so entirely
what we are accustomed to these changes
if you multiply them by hundreds of
changes right it becomes almost
unintelligible to the average person
when they read the old books of hadith
the ancient books of that's why the
scholars keep writing books on keep
writing books on keep writing books on
explaining hadith they're not saying
anything new our religion is not a
religion of innovation it's a religion
of tradition we don't say new things but
what we're doing is we are the scholars
they are merging
that what is written with what we are
living and existing in today. That's
their job. That's one of the biggest
jobs that they have and one of their
biggest challenges. There's no such
thing as a person discovering new
discoveries of the Quran. Right? The
entirety of the meanings of the Quran
was known in its entirety to the prophet
and his companions sallall.aii wasallam.
and the entirety of the Quran's meanings
are known to the ummah as a whole at any
given time throughout history. However,
there may be new things that change with
regards to our existence that may
coincide with things that are mentioned
in the Quran. Generalities that are
gestured to in the Quran. This is not
you know the the you know an
innovative cuttingedge
you know advancement in the sciences
of Islam. Alhamdulillah our religion is
preserved and our religion is complete.
there's nothing left to discover about
it, but there is a lot left to to
uncover with regards to the masses at
any given time. And so the best book and
the book that is often overlooked when
it comes to the s is the Quran. It is
the most detailed account and the Quran
only mentions the most important and
critical points of the prophet
sallall.aii
wasallam. However, it's not mentioned in
chronological order. It's not mentioned
in order of revelation. It's mentioned
with regards to what is appropriate for
a bigger picture that is the Quran.
You move on to another book that will
help you understand the Quran very well
is a book the sealed nectar. It
doesn't have a lot of weak or
fabricated narrations in it many
books on the topic. it doesn't have a
lot of conjecture and presupposition
in it and extrapolating meanings
that aren't there. mafi it's a very
good book and one of the you know one of
the evidences that a book is good that a
book is in general as a whole
acceptable is when a book becomes common
place and household
wherever you go you find that book if I
say for instance taps what taps do you
find in every library everywhere
everywhere in the world in every masid.
Huh?Bes
everybody. That's the first that came to
mind. Even though there are hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of te
if you were to spend your entire life
only reading books of tea properly, you
would die long before you get to the end
of them. So how is it that this one book
made it to become a household name? It's
because Allah
subh Allah chooses from his creation and
the offerings of his slaves. What he
chooses if I were to say a book on
what is a book that is good for that
comes to mind.
Well, that would be more in hadith like
just specifically
what to say when you go in the
bathroom, what to say when you come out,
what to say when you wake up, what to
say when you go to sleep.
[Arabic recitation]
Well, maybe this one. There's a little
There's a little book. Have you guys
thinking of it? , Fortress of the
Muslim. Yeah. Muslim. It used to be
printed for years and years. It was
orange, bright orange, right? And it was
given out in mass to anyone who went to
Haj or Omar. Anyone who passed by Saudi
just casually would end up with one of
those books.
It's in every single house. After all
these years of studying, it's still one
of the best books I've ever come across
and it is so common place and so
accessible.
There's hundreds of books that have been
written on that topic. That's not the
only one. Everyone, any scholar who is
worth his salt will want to write two
things before he dies. A book on and a
book on. Those are the two most
desirable things to to write on as a
scholar. Why? Because there's nothing
more better. There's nothing better than
knowledge of the Quran, right?
And there is nothing more rewarding than
having millions of people read from your
book every morning and every night
throughout the entirety of their day.
Right? However, this book was chosen. If
I were to say a book of hadith, what
book comes to mind?
by
every you know it is the most printed
book
after the mus in the entire Muslim
library in the entire Islamic library.
It is the most printed book out of any
other books after the the mus the book
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Is that
the only book that's in its vein?
Hundreds of books have been written on
hadith compilations.
Some more clever, more clear than a
Noah's book. Some more authentic, some
more accessible, but that was the one
that was chosen. And this articulates
something about the author, and that is
that the author has reached a level that
he is as a whole, doesn't mean
everything, but as a whole, this book
has been accepted by Allah. This is an
evidence of intentions that he had pure
intentions when he wrote this book.
Likewise,
is that the only book written in as a as
a type of book? Of course not.
Hundreds of books have been written on
that. Right? You have
Muslim.
There are, you know, if we were to say a
book on a compilation of hadith, a
book that is a beginner's book on
hadith, you would think of the 40
narrations of
if I were to say a book on prophetic
medicine.
There are books written on prophetic
medicine. most that comes to mind is
for
which is actually just the fifth volume
or the fourth volume of his book.
Right? If I were to say a book on the
stories of the prophets, what book comes
to mind?
Huh?
[Arabic recitation]
It's Ib Kir. Yeah, it's Ib Kir. That's
actually just the first volume from
Niha, a bigger book on on history
written by Ib Kad, but it's everywhere.
I could stand up right now and pull all
of those books out of this shelf behind
me right now without even knowing that
they're there because this is how Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala chooses things.
When I
went to write his book al
was groundbreaking in its time
because this is before
and
one of the most prolific students
of Alam Malik he said
He said there is no book under the
canopy of our sky that is more authentic
under under the sky under the heavens
that is more authentic than mik.
There were many other books written as a
ma. A ma is a type of book just a
sah is a type of book in the science of
hadith. It's a category of book right
and he was asked and Imam Malik was
asked why are you writing this
when others who are more well-known
than yourself have written more
expansive
before you this is something that's
already been done why are you
reinventing the wheel basically he said
he said whatever is truly for Allah's
sake will remain and whatever is not for
fame or notoriety or even even
for for vanity right knowledge is
vanity just just money is
vanity
or vanity it will dissipate. How many of
us have ever heard of a written by other
than Imam Malik? Never. You have to
specialize in the science of hadith to
even read about those books. And most of
them are lost.
Meaning we don't have their copies
anymore. They're gone. All we have is
the name that this was once written.
These are books that are considered to
be.
Right? This is how Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala chooses of his creation. Now this
doesn't mean that just because something
is popular that means it's automatically
correct. No, this follows
it being adopted or deemed acceptable by
the scholars of Islam. We always follow
the scholars. We never say something the
scholars don't say before us. This is
important. They come to the conclusions
we follow them. Right?
But if the scholars from amongst all the
books that the scholars accept,
these are the most ubiquitous and the
most well-known and the most common
place. This articulates a level of
sincerity that the author would have.
And this articulates that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has accepted and
it's not just books as well. When we
look at the issue of
a med what is a med? It's a school of
thought. Is there only four schools of
thought? Is that something that is
written in the sunnah? Did the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam say there will
only be four schools of thought? No.
There's dozens of schools of thought. Mo
every major scholar had a school of
thought. What is his school of thought?
The conclusions that he arrived at and
more specifically the formulas he used
in order to arrive at those conclusions.
how we understand evidence is and what
the and what the byproduct of that
understanding is or the conclusions
of those evidences are in that
understanding is that's what a med is.
There are dozens of med but only four of
them are
truly preserved today. There there is
a fifth the med of the
which has some contributions but
overall it it is it is not considered
to be on par with the other four and
then there is always the mh ofith which
choose from those four but many many
many major scholars had a mhab im Muslim
was known to have a medi
Abu Dani
they weren't orfi or hali or right they
they were on the level of these scholars
to where they can arrive at their own
opinions
but they didn't have the students and
they didn't have the acceptance in that
field to where their med was documented
as meticulously as those four
that we have today.
Alazi. He was shafer but due to his
his you know his excellence in the
field of he was viewed to have his
own med in the sense working around
the med of
however these four they are the ones
that stuck because this is when we look
through the history of Islam there's
certain scholars there's certain books
There are certain mad certain opinions
that Allah preserves and the rest
retreat into the bowels of history.
having said that, we didn't say anything
about
because it's your fault. You're the one
that you said
Ali went off on some tangent.
for
subhanahu
forchech.
[Silence]
Just a reminder, tonight is Thursday
night. as we usually remind everyone
the best salah of the week to attend
and the most virtuous one of all the
five daily prayers of the entirety of
the week is
in the masid on the morning of
as the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam mentioned if you don't usually
come to fud in the masid you know a lot
of people don't but if you wanted to
choose one to come to that would be the
perfect place to start